tristan étudiant à l'université de saint
quentin en yvelines milite depuis deux
ans au sein des jeunes de génération
mouvement créé par benoît hamon le 1er
juillet 2017 ce mardi 5 février le parti
lance sa journée de défense du service
public
ce tour de france du service public
c'est de leur redonner la part leur
donner l'occasion de se mobiliser leur
donner l'occasion que tout le monde
puisse la voir commettre leur mot
d'ordre est que nous puissions ben voilà
avec eux travailler sur de nouvelles
alternatives à toutes ces questions à
voir quels sont leurs besoins
concrètement sur le terrain aujourd'hui
le service public a aujourd'hui c'est le
lier c'est le pacte républicain c'est le
pacte social c'est ce qui fait que nous
sommes égaux en droit et dans les fêtes
en cette journée de grève nationale
il participe à l'assemblée générale des
cheminots dans les locaux de la cgt en
gare de versailles chantiers
le but avec génération c'est qu'on
vienne voir tous les acteurs du service
public
aujourd'hui c'est une grosse journée de
mobilisation c'est l'occasion pour nous
aussi participer à des actions locales
la cgt est à l'initiative de cette grève
nationale de 24 heures un mouvement pour
réclamer une hausse des salaires une
meilleure justice fiscale
des militants et des gilets jaunes ont
d'ailleurs bloqué le marché
international de rungis dès minuit
la mobilisation s'est achevée à 5 heures
ce mardi matin
oui nous n'avons pas de doléances
vis-à-vis du gouvernement nous avons des
revendications apporter à nos employeurs
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on est en
grève aujourd'hui en cessation du
travail fdt on a de moins en moins de
moyens pour faire les choses qu'on
transporte les gens dans des wagons à
bestiaux qui sont mal entretenues qu' il
n'y a pas les moyens humains pour
pouvoir assurer du service je ne me
rends compte que parfois le chemin de
fer fonctionnaient mieux au 19e siècle
parce qu'il y avait des gens nous
réclamons les hausses de salaires et des
pensions pour nos anciens aussi les
jeunes de génération continuent leur
tour de france dans les yvelines
ils se sont rendus dans l'après midi à
l'hôpital de plaisir